direction de la ville de lviv en ukraine
où l'on retrouve culliver craag notre
envoyé spécial à l'ouest du pays vous
avez des informations bien sûr sur
l'ensemble de l'ukraine la population
civile arrive-t-elle encore à partir de
kiev la capitale
oui pour le moment il est encore
possible d'entrer et de sortir de kiev
par le sud est mais on pense que les
russes vont tenter d'encercler la ville
notamment ils essayent de prendre la
ville de vassil qu'yves au sud de la
capitale où les ukrainiens ont déjà
repoussé des attaques mais aujourd'hui
l'aérodrome de la ville a été ciblée et
selon le maire de vassiliki l'aérodrome
a été complètement détruite cela peut
être une partie de cette tentative
d'encercler kiev mais ça rentre aussi
dans la logique de du fait que les
russes cible les aérodromes à travers
tout le pays y compris dans l'ouest de
l'ukraine alousque qui est une ville au
nord de la ville où là aussi l'aérodrome
selon le maire de la ville toujours
auraient été détruits cela est peut-être
une stratégie des russes pour empêcher
les ukrainiens de pouvoir utiliser les
avions de combat que la pologne
notamment leur promet mais il n'est pas
clair si ces avions vont être livrées ou
non pour revenir à kiev il y à aussi
l'offensif terriens qui arrive depuis le
nord-est est depuis le nord ouest de
kiev la question c'est est-ce que les
forces russes ont déjà pu traverser la
rivière entre kiev et ir pin cette
banlieue de kiev qui a été évacué en
grande partie ces derniers jours selon
certains témoignages reporter dans les
médias ukrainiens il aurait
effectivement traversé cette rivière est
avancé donc avant serait donc vers le
centre de la capitale et par ailleurs
que se passe-t-il en ce moment dans le
donbass
oui on a beaucoup parlé de marioupol
cette ville portuaire dans le sud de la
région d'udine base qui est assiégé les
habitants ne peuvent pas sortir ils
n'ont pas d'eau ni chauffage ni beaucoup
de nourriture il y a vraiment une
catastrophe humanitaire à marioupol mais
il y a aussi une offensif vers le nord
en partant des enclave tenue par les
soi-disant séparatistes donc
effectivement par la russie depuis 2014
vers le nord l'offensive se poursuit et
notamment les villes de severodonetsk de
licite chance qu ont été bombardées et
sous des tirs d'artillerie aujourd'hui
et hier j'ai parlé tout à l'heure un
habitant de l'institut qui a dit qu au
moment où on parlait les tirs continuer
et il m'a dit que l'école où il est allé
à l'école enfants avaient été touchés
aujourd'hui je pense que les garçons
n'étaient pas là mais c'est encore une
énième preuve du fait que les russes
cible l'infrastructure civile merci
beaucoup d'univers crack merci à vous